[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but for this once proud city to survive
a new champion must rise
steve wake up are you pretending to be
asleep right now
listen steve might not look like much
but there is a champion monster inside
of him did he eat one
thank you that felt great
maybe they're right winning's not really
my thing
not yet we start training tomorrow
6 a.m
you're you're serious
let's start over what do you love to do
sleeping really sitting not helping oh
there's also dancing what
i don't like dancing that's so
[Music]
okay yes
i love dancing wrestling is 80
footwork
not bad for 22 tons
are you ready to save this city yeah
execute playing tango
holy guacamole and chips for lunch today
you want to kiss a very questionable
opponent and dancing it's a disgrace to
the sport for a total joke that's how i
felt my whole life but you believed in
me
okay enough with the sappy stuff ugh
it's showtime we need to beat the
biggest hammer
the baddest
yes you are and the slightest oh it's in
my mouth there's not gonna be a thing
left of these cows or you
this is gonna be fun bro
well
[Music]
it is go time
[ __ ] up put your game face on
and if you live let's get froyo
afterwards oh i love froze wait if i
live
[Music]
bye